a gay duck
[Music]
and to be a gay duck in the united arab
emirates lauren please don't downplay
that
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to another episode of yes or no
this is a very special episode because
this is the first episode that we've
ever had a girl
on
this would be my friend lauren southern
lauren the filmmaker behind american
mirage coming out soon lots of other
great projects lauren only recently
welcomed back into america i think
previously you were barred from this
country i was but first i have some
horrendous news for you okay i'm legally
a man in canada did you just call me a
woman i'm legally a man
are you you oh yes okay this is good no
i'm so glad that you reminded me of this
because i felt
look i'm a married man okay i generally
follow the mike pence rule i try not to
go drinking with ladies i just it's not
it's not a good look okay men and women
are different but i am so pleased to be
reminded that you are in fact and
drinking it's a man's game you know
against the pub have some cigars this is
for us men only you're right just for us
fellas are you ready for
the game i think so okay i guess so well
because
because i forgot you were a man
i prepared for ladies to go first
australia is somehow even worse than
canada all right
no i'm afraid you got that wrong
what yeah
yeah australia is not worse than canada
because australia is a prison colony
it's it's full of really tough wild old
guys crocodile dundee that sort of thing
they've got a much funnier accent okay
well you got yours right
i did good okay cheers i will just drink
whenever of course during the game
really the way to play
i also think often about how it's hard
being a conservative
in this world right now and wanting to
promote you know staying away from the
vices
yeah how are you supposed to not be an
alcoholic well things are the state they
are that's true and listen everything in
moderation i mean it's almost noon time
around it's almost lunch time it's five
o'clock somewhere right now too true
okay so now i read one
brunettes are taken more seriously and
are more trustworthy than blondes
how would you answer that
oh i've mixed things up here
i'm generally unobservant so i hadn't
noticed until now you've changed
not only your sex but your hair color
you got it right
you got it right too i know so neither
of us drinks so obvious right can i
drink anyway of course wonderful
we would like why we won why wouldn't we
drink
you have to drink when you lose and you
get to drink when you win that's
wonderful the right attitude
it is more likely that justin trudeau is
the son of fidel castro
then joe biden won a fair election in
2020.
this is going to require some very high
level logic so it's more likely
that justin trudeau is the son of fidel
castro than joe biden won a fair
election okay
[Music]
depends okay
um
of course and i'll say for the record i
actually don't think that justin is
fidel castro's son i know that his
mother
was an eccentric character i know that
they were friends with the castros i
know that justin trudeau looks exactly
like fidel castro
intellectually spiritually and
physically i know that
but but
i actually see a little bit of his
father in him yeah it's a toss-up it's a
fun meme though i appreciate it i
respect the people who uh are
spreading misinformation on the internet
misinformation with misinformation of
course no you do and you you can pretty
much do anything for a meme
but certainly we can say it is much more
likely that
fidel castro is the father of justin
then that
joe biden won a fair election they
rigged the whole damn thing they said
the the big tech oligarch said you
couldn't spread true information about
biden corruption they changed all the
rules in the weeks before the election
they violated the state constitution of
pennsylvania
yeah this is what i find
interesting is to me it doesn't have to
be anything to do with the ballots just
the state of the media i saw uh leftists
jumping up and down about victor orban's
win in hungary and they were
yeah that horrible horrible man of
europe yeah they said this is an unfair
election lauren because they banned you
know media companies that were opposed
to victor they banned all of these you
know ngos and everything and i'm like
so what is it in america when all these
right-wing outlets get censored was that
an unfair election then all right if
that's the rule fine right right
i loved one time uh victor orban was
accused of all the same stuff that
anyone to the right of hillary clinton
gets accused of you know you're a racist
anti-semitic this that and the other
thing goes why you you say i'm
anti-semantic they said well because
you've criticized george soros so well
if that qualifies you as anti-semitic he
said very plainly he said george soros
is a hungarian and a major political
rival of mine who spends a lot of money
trying to remove me from power i think i
get to criticize him i think i get to
push back a little bit i think the most
anti-semitic thing you can possibly say
is that george soros represents all jews
i've never heard you hatred any any
worse than suggesting yeah good point
should we drink oh yeah again wonderful
love that should have asked for a double
homosexuality is more nature than
nurture
hmm
hmm
you were right
you were wrong i was wrong you say it's
uh homosexuality is more nature than
nurture
yeah i don't know i think that there's
i find it difficult to think you could
indoctrinate a man out of wanting
sex with a woman
what if you put him in prison
yeah that's environmental for sure but
you're saying he would still probably
prefer the woman yes
yes so that there are men that in a free
environment where they could sleep with
women choose to sleep with men instead
i find that very interesting i think
it's also like a sex drive thing
like men and gay men in particular tend
to have like very very high sex drives
and they're just like you know what
women aren't going to keep up
with that about it
i do remember in my teenage years i
would sometimes friends would say ah if
only i had been made a gay man i would
be so much happier you know i would have
all of my desires fulfilled the reason i
say no yeah
and that you correctly guessed my answer
is not because i think that people
aren't born with a certain uh attraction
or desire or anything like that you know
sometimes people will argue that there's
no way that there's any biological or
genetic or early infant basis for uh
sexual attraction i think well that's
crazy why not and they'll say because
god doesn't make mistakes you're saying
well i think people are born with six
fingers i don't know people are born
with all sorts of this is a fallen world
are there all sorts of peculiarities and
eccentricities but the reason i say that
homosexuality is more nurture really i
would say i guess it's more culture is
that there's a difference between having
a sexual desire and
indulging that sexual desire or creating
a sexual identity based on that desire i
mean the very idea of homosexuality
is very modern not because some guys
didn't want to shut up other guys in the
past but just the idea that that was a
sexual identity look back at the ancient
greeks they were all shipping each other
but they didn't view themselves as
liberace or something like that there
seems to be a huge amount of culture
here the idea that
what is it now more than
greater than one in five gen z youth
identify as lgbt up from historically
about one percent yeah either
alex jones is right and there's
something in the water or or and he's
and he actually was right about the
water with the frogs but but in addition
to that you might say that there's some
cultural phenomenon going on here
i agree with that when it comes to
especially the
like 72 different genders and pronouns
stuff i think that is absolutely nurture
but when it comes to like the actual
like sexual stuff that we've seen the
desire the dawn of time you know uh that
that to me there is a nature aspect but
it's a really good point because you can
take it outside of sex too i mean what
you're describing is that people have a
kind of lower will they have an appetite
whether it's a natural desire or a
desire that has been inculcated into us
we have these things but then we have a
rational will and we can say well i
actually don't want to do this you know
i don't want to have the 10th beer i
mean i do but or we don't i don't want
to have 20 more cookies i have i'm going
to get a stomachache right you have that
higher will and that's why you can say
the things i want to do i don't do and
the things that i don't want to do i do
and so
leaving aside even for a moment the
morality of engaging in homosexual
behavior certainly you have to admit
there is a social and a cultural
aspect to all of that over whether or
not you're going to do in the first
place
yeah yeah for sure
okay all right well we've already gotten
you canceled you've already you just
called every gay guy in america rapist i
think okay so now not a good show if you
don't get a media matters article out of
it
the immigration crisis at the american
southern border is more important than
russia invading ukraine
you were right
i only say that because you're american
though
um
so was i right
i'm torn you should put the drink in the
middle
if you stand in the middle of the road
lauren you're gonna get hit by a truck i
just finished a documentary on the
american border crisis and i think it's
extremely important but
obviously if you're ukrainian if you're
russian that's going to be more
important to you and then the
geopolitical fallout all of that it's
it's hard to say it's hard to say how
can america make the argument that
ukraine's borders are sacred if we don't
believe in our own borders yeah it's
simple enough to me i'm not saying it's
even describing the threats to the world
order although i do think that in
america without borders which is to say
in america that's not really a nation i
think that's a huge threat to the the
world order if we're supposed to be the
global hegemon and we can't even control
our own borders but furthermore if the
argument is nations should have their
borders respected
big powerful countries although frankly
russia seems less powerful than i think
a lot of us believed it would be before
the invasion but big powerful countries
shouldn't invade smaller weaker
countries well how can we make that
argument when we won't protect our own
borders
yeah yeah i think back to
like the old ben shapiro debates on tv
about gun control and him saying but we
have to the second amendment is for
you know if there's an invading force
it's not for just going to your gun
range right now
and everyone would just laugh at that
and say when is that going to happen
right because we've got a you know
50-year at best memory span right and
every other nation on earth especially
china russia they're thinking on
hundred-year timelines not four-year
election cycles they're like okay we
have been shamed we've had those years
of shame we're now going to take over
the south china sea we're going to have
this plan we're going to execute for a
hundred years we remember invasions we
remember all this americans canadians
forget about it
and by the way we're not even talking
about the guatemalan economic migrant
who just wants to make some money for
his family there are
there are terrorists who are arrested
trying to cross into our border there
are foreign nationals who are up to all
sorts of problems who who are
apprehended and sometimes not
apprehended coming into our country when
i was uh on the reynosa border right
across from mcallen texas they've got a
country club on the other side and i
guess the u.s government couldn't buy
the space to put the border wall so the
border wall just stops and then it's
just country club and every night there
they've got people going over in boats
we're flying our drone over and there's
boats across the whole shore
and in the abandoned buildings where
migrants will wait before they go to
this texan country club there's spray
paint of 18th street gang all over them
and that's an el salvadorian competitor
gang to ms-13 and i'm like they're not
spray painting this because they own
this territory they're spray painting it
before they go into america most likely
successfully and like i witnessed that
with my own eyes you've got gang members
from el salvador every day
making their way through mexico up into
the u.s it's not usually what you think
of when you think of a country club you
usually think of guys wearing you know
gold button blazers here instead of
shuffling ms-13 gang-banging psychos
into america yeah yeah that's a scary
situation absolutely
worthwhile to drink even though we both
guessed right the canadian government
hates christians more than it hates
muslim extremists
i'm gonna do a soft slide so i don't
spill again all right
somehow you did spill on it i don't know
how it doesn't make any sense it's
rigged all right it's right it's rigged
uh you're correct as are you it goes
without saying it's not i did you ever
watch that norm mcdonald episode where
he interviews the girl about 9 11 and
she says the unfortunate thing about 9
11 was all the hate that it caused
against muslims i feel like that's kind
of the canadian government's response to
the issue whereas they see like the
church burnings that happened over last
summer you know like 50 churches more
than that vandalized attacked burnt to
the ground and on bs yeah on bs grounds
and they put out a little statement oh
that's not so good and ignore it we know
that if that were mosques
just
you know trudeau would be doing a tour
across the country no there is no
question the worst part about canadian
leftists burning down dozens and dozens
of churches is the potential blowback
precisely michael all right welcome well
done cheers
i'm actually into the idea of the
metaverse
yeah no i know i'm a normal person i i
want to live in a world created by god
not a world created by some weird
reptilian named zuckerberg yeah yeah i
think i'll pass on that one i played
enough second life in high school to
know that yeah hey you're not a big fan
yeah you know this like beautiful
glorious creation with waterfalls and
love and joy and hope what if you just
live in sims all the time yeah that'll
be fun right that sounds great people
wouldn't pick that though that's that's
how sad and miserable things are getting
plus in the metaverse you don't even get
legs did you know that you don't get
laid no they got rid of they got rid of
legs actually everything below your
navel because i this is not a joke there
was too much groping going on in the
metaverse in the beta testing they
people kept groping and so they got rid
of their legs and loins and everything
and but there was still kind of groping
so now there's a
six foot virtual barrier between all the
characters my safe space can't grope me
if i don't have a body the patriarchy
always finds a way okay
using the term magga if you're not
american
is a very offensive and harmful form of
cultural appropriation
so true
so true
yeah no i'm going to say actually
no
it's not cultural
appropriation because
whether you like it or not america is
the global empire it it runs the entire
world and there's nothing even close the
russians
the russian invasion of ukraine it
totally proves this everyone thought oh
okay you know russia it's this really
strong
form it was recently a superpower no
it's nothing it's there's nothing even
close there's america which has all the
guns and all the weapons and all the
power and everything and then there's
everyone else below the ta i can't even
find everyone else here it's the
asymmetries are so crazy and so i'm not
saying that's a good thing
i'm not saying it's a bad thing but it's
the way it is and so in a sense we're
all living in the american empire i love
america but i think you're you're
doing the american thing where you
overestimate your country unfortunately
china russia they're playing the long
game no they're not all they have to do
is wait to win yes no i'm i'm not even
disputing that i'm not saying that
america is going to remain that way
forever yeah you know
pride goeth before destruction and a
haughty spirit before a fall yeah but
right now today
we're all american
all right all right well i will
happily culturally appropriate then
now that i've been given the mega pass
that's believable so wait that's a bit
contradictory in itself so make america
great again but our country is already
the greatest
got him
wow got him
it's like
yeah you're right it's could you be
you could be very very powerful but not
great
right in the sense that
you at the height of roman decadence
at the height of just vicious debauched
roman decadence it was it was the world
empire
but was it great in a moral sense
probably not
got him back spiritually
australia during covet is basically
afghanistan without abrahamic religion
and a full-body version of masks
australia during covet is basically
afghanistan without abrahamic religion
and a full-body version of masks i mean
yes i i guess the concept right like
i was told by the government when i
could and couldn't leave my house uh
anywhere i went had to be tracked by uh
you know the government which is clearly
run by the patriarchy and men so i had
to have tabs on myself by men constantly
everyone had apps on their phone
whenever you went into a store even in
uber you had to scan the app and it
would literally have a list of locations
you had been all day all month wherever
and that would be sent off into a
government database think about how
valuable that data is that is so you can
know where every 30 year old woman is at
4pm on a tuesday afternoon in australia
wow that is like extremely powerful
levels of data that is i i would have to
say you got it wrong
oh okay because
well one because uh the western liberal
establishment has been able to
successfully occupy australia unlike
afghanistan which it completely botched
for 20 years
and also because afghanistan has heroin
you know they've got very valuable opium
at least they've got heroin they've got
something they've got they've got a very
valuable export australia these days i
don't even know what they're exporting
it's been 30 years it's crocodile dundee
what do they have outback steakhouse is
their biggest
export and we own that
so true so true you're stuck in your
house and you don't even have heroin i
know or a bloomin onion horrendous oh
bloomin onion
okay
a trans man is i guess personal a trans
man dating a trans woman is just a
straight couple with extra steps
i think by definition
yeah well i know um they just came out
with recent research that showed oh it's
like
ridiculously low like somewhere between
one only one to ten percent of
transgender people actually are
meaningfully transgender in fact i think
it's the one percent in that they
actually get surgery to change anything
at all
so technically the majority of people
that identify as transgender would still
have the original parts you know i'm
actually
as you say that i'm gonna change my
answer okay let's see this i've just had
an epiphany in real time because yeah
you know
sure technically it's still a dude and a
chick even though but the very fact that
they're pretending that the dude is the
chick and the chick is the dude would
seem to me to suggest it's not the same
thing as a straight couple because i
know this is very politically incorrect
i think men and women have different
roles in marriage now we use this stupid
word relationship you know i'm in a
relationship like you're i'm a
partnership like you're starting an
accounting firm or something but no when
you're in a marriage husbands and wives
do different things different roles
different just kind of different
categories and so if you've got the dude
pretending to be the chick and the chick
pretending to be the dude it's not just
the same thing as a straight couple it's
kind of the opposite of a straight
couple
yeah reverse but i guess it like you're
talking about a traditional straight
couple because the modern straight
couple they do do switcheroos all the
time like the stay-at-home husband the
yes you know you make a good point even
the very concept of straight like the
idea that you need this separate
category for straight you're right okay
i changed my i changed my answer back
you're right lauren you convinced me
again you've brought me back from the
brink wonderful okay
uh is it me
a form of pedophilia will be added to
lgbtq plus
will be added to the lgbtq plus cause
and be in the process of being
normalized before the 2024 presidential
election
it's because of the and it's not gonna
it's not
it is in the process of being normalized
you're seeing professors now come out
and say we shouldn't use the word
pedophilia that's that's stigmatized we
should say mine are attracted persons
who push this
but i they're not going to do it before
2024 and they're they're probably not
going to add it to the initialism just
because it's bad optics right it's bad
pr
yeah that's the only reason i said no as
well is i think what is it yeah 2024 is
too soon give them another 10 years yeah
i uh
i saw a meme recently that was saying
if gay marriage gets legalized what is
going to happen and then it just has a
big bar graph that says gay people will
be happy and below it has a bunch of
other options that's like disease will
spread across the world the terrorists
will win you know the election
russia will invade and then it's like
but all of the options below did
actually eventually happen jokes aside
and people still aren't happy
you know it's a fallen world man none of
us ever you know you're not gonna if you
make your identity just about who you
stop you're not gonna have a great life
yeah yeah the slippery slope has been
very real though that's one thing that i
think everyone can at least give
conservatives the slippery slope
is not a fallacy
no the slippery sl the only thing that's
fallacious about the slippery slope is
you never seem to get to the bottom of
it
every time you think i'm at the bottom i
cannot we we are now talking about
grooming five-year-olds and talking
about you know pumping them full of
cross-sex hormones there's no way we can
oh no i'm not going down even further
and they're going to normalize yeah what
is that exact quote it's uh the light at
the end of the tunnel is another train
wonderful american politics probably
probably true
women with a high body count are more
i think this is referring to certain
romantic relationships women with a high
body count are more miserable later in
life
yeah i i guess i agree with what with
one caveat
people can commit all sorts of terrible
things you know when i was young and
irresponsible i was young and
irresponsible and
they can turn their lives around they
can actually change their minds they can
repent they can go live a
way better life joy is available to them
ultimate salvation is available to them
but it is true
that
even all of that notwithstanding
you are probably going to regret
your
well
you're going to regret it you're going
to have those pain i mean that is there
is a temporal effect of all sorts of sin
but the only reason i'm hung up here is
on easter christians always say
oh happy fault that won for me so great
so glory is a redeemer that we actually
celebrate the fall of mankind and the
the original sin in the garden of eden
because we get the redeemer we get a
salvation out of that even though it was
a problem to do in the first place so
you could see a world and i know people
like this who say man i lived a
debauched terrible disgusting degenerate
life
but hey it brought me to god i wouldn't
be here today if i hadn't done that
so i'm kind of i'm really torn i'm
really torn on that yeah logically
speaking i mean it doesn't it just seem
reasonable that if you find the person
you love and want to spend the rest of
your life with them and that's the
person you sleep with and you don't have
to go through like
10 000 failed relationships and
experiences that you'll necessarily be
more happy also
you know
sex especially like in marriage for
years and years when you work on that
and you build it up i think it's way
better yeah
yeah yeah now listen
i saw
there was a meme that just came out it
said getting married in your 20s is like
leaving a party at 8 o'clock
and i thought hold on so you're telling
me i could leave a party early with a
woman that i get to go sleep with for
many many times over many many years or
i can just hang out until 2am and go
home alone i don't think so trying to
get a girl to come home with you having
all these unsuccessful kind of half
things yeah no i will say i like your
point about um forgiveness though
because that's one thing that i really
would love to see more especially in
conservatism there's no forgiveness on
the left right now it's pure oh you
tweeted something 15 years ago well time
to execute you uh and
on the right there is this opportunity
to say oh you're broken and we have to
say that because
we've all grown up in a broken world
especially millennials like you really
think millennials aren't going to have
sex before marriage do drugs do all
these things of course they are it's all
around them 24 encouraged to yeah so you
have to offer a path for
something
better and also admit our own faults
like i i think that's a big problem in
conservative creation as well like we
are all very fallen people
conservative creators as everyone who
watches us it's about trying to aspire
for something better and more
so yeah thank god for god
cheers to that cheers for that
just like political commentary is for
failed actors documentaries are for
failed filmmakers wow
i'm just gonna say you say no and you
better say no too
no i i would say no both i assume you
would say no but i also would say no
because
what about verner herzog i don't think
the guy was going to be in you know guys
and dolls i don't think the guy wanted
to be you know playing woody and toy
story the guy is a documentarian and
that's a very high form of art
and he's very good at it hmm actually
you just made me rethink my answer the
other way
i think that art is the best way to
communicate with people
you can't make someone care about
you know a
stalin quote um you know a million is
just a statistic whereas one that's like
someone you can sympathize with that's a
tragedy um and you look at
any any documentary on a subject if it's
just pure around the facts about a
subject a lot of people watch it and
people who are fact-minded they'll enjoy
it but it's those emotional movies made
about wars made about tragedies that
really make people care and get involved
i agree that that narrative storytelling
is more powerful
but you
still i think some people are just
documentarians and i don't think it's
that they're failed
uh you know showgirls or something you
you wouldn't say that a math look i
think that telling stories is probably
more important than a lot of high-level
mathematics
but you wouldn't say the mathematician
is a failed artist
you would just say he's a mathematician
it's a different thing it's got value to
it yeah it does but i'll tell you right
now if i had the budget for it i'd move
to filmmaking instead of documentaries
right away could i be a showgirl in the
movie you can absolutely i will cast you
for sure as a show girl i just i look at
it and i don't think any
like i think the girl in the little red
dress in schindler's list did more for
talking about uh you know
tragedies during world war ii
than
history classes in school that most
people zone out in yeah that's true like
i think those kind of little artistic
they touch people's souls right yeah
that is hard to do with numbers that is
true
joseph conrad says that the job of the
artist is to render the highest possible
justice to the visible world
and you know that's something that
we people who just own the libs on the
internet that's that's it's a i agree
it's a higher calling all right i'll
still drink
always got to finish it before the end
before we get to this question lauren oh
i
really can't wait to tell people about
ring
right now go to ring.com
michael you know about ring i've told
you about ring for years it's that
amazing video doorbell where you can see
and speak to whoever is at your door
wherever you are in the world in your
house at the office wherever
then maybe you heard about ring alarm
ring alarm is great you get to keep
track of your whole home protect it not
just from the bad guys but from freeze
from fire well what if i told you that
you could go pro that's right you can
get ring alarm pro and that way you are
not just protecting your physical home
but you're protecting your digital home
too think about how much time we spend
in the digital virtual world so that's
great you're protecting your door and
your windows but what about your data
well with ring alarm pro you can also
protect your wi-fi you can also protect
all of those infra digital information
that are going all around your home so
make sure you go right now to ring.com
michael that's
m-i-c-h-a-e-l
with a ring protect pro subscription
which is an amazing deal you get that
professional monitoring ultimate peace
of mind that is ring.com
michael m-i-c-h-a-e-l
all right picking back up the game
i am legally banned from the united
kingdom
very funny you really got me with that
one you got it right i'm allowed into
the united states wow that's so cool
you're allowed into that trash country
congratulations michael have fun
drinking and watching footy into
oblivion while your country's destroyed
who who banned you it wasn't the queen
it was the queen herself actually she
came down and told me how dare you
lauren
tough old german lady you know she is i
think i'm one of the only women in the
world to be arrested for terrorism
though
so that's very feminist to me in my
opinion yeah that's
history you're breaking the glass
ceiling i'm a trailblazer truly okay
well
that who needs it who needs those minds
anyway
okay
europe
not believing in jesus christ is the
main cause of people turning into total
libs
oh
[Music]
no i it is
it is it's just as simple as that
because it all it all really comes out
of the french revolution and the french
revolution was a rejection of christ and
his church and the enlightenment project
broadly was a rejection of christ in his
church and that is the
beginning of liberalism so it is in a
very literal way it is wait but do do
protestants not believe in jesus christ
no they do but what if they're the cause
well some do some do not all do some
rejected i i happen to agree with you
you know the reformation led to the
complete uh
um questioning of any sort of
structure and definitions suddenly you
can go into your own little closet and
decide what you want anything to be
there doesn't have to be an authority or
anything to tell you which good and bad
aspects to that but definitely let us
down an interesting path um but yeah
still a lot of
a lot of protestants episcopalians you
know you've got a lot of denominations
so are you are you blaming the
protestants for the french revolution
because i might but i didn't think
i'm just saying
there's a lot of liberal protestants
that believe in jesus no there there are
there are i mean there are the libcats
to the liberal catholics for those who
aren't up on the lingo
they are too but again i do think a lot
of that
i
mean
modernity begins with the protestant
revolution there's no question about
that uh and the protestant revolution
does play into aspects of the french
revolution there's no question about
that the french revolution is where we
get the terms left and right even right
the right were the people who supported
the monarchy in the left were the big
libs and so there's there's no question
about all of that and there's a very
interesting conversation to be had about
the role of mr luther in all of these
things
but i think at a very basic level when
we talk about
liberalism
lowercase l capital l leftism
progressivism all of it
it does appear to all have come out of a
rejection of the authority of
the church and christianity
yeah of course there has to be some
structure when you believe in
christianity but did god himself not
give us freedom to eat of the tree
well there was a punishment i mean did
he didn't right he said don't do it and
then we had this free will really it
really uh we probably shouldn't
shouldn't have used it except that that
happy fault gave to us so great so
glorious a redeemer yeah now
it's even further complicated because
this
mucky soup of liberalism that we all
just find ourselves mired in has colored
as you point out very insightfully the
way that christians even view themselves
yeah christians have become very liberal
in many ways which is a very sad thing i
wouldn't even say that so like
christianity does
mimic
aspects of you have personal freedom so
there's aspects of liberalism you have
that personal freedom so the problem
isn't the personal freedom itself it's
the choices we're making with said
personal freedom spoken like a true
protestant cheers
cheers
all
right getting married and being a mother
is the highest good for a woman and
should be the priority in life
the the only reason i say no the only
reason i say no is i think
not everyone is called to be married not
everyone is called to motherhood
some people are physically incapable of
becoming mothers i'm not just talking
about men who think that they're women
but women too
but religious life is a high calling now
people laugh about it you say what do
you want me to become a nun well yeah
some of the greatest people in history
have been nuns and had consecrated
religious life but but generally
for the vast majority of women i would
say yes yeah i'm a no as well there are
people that uh i know
where i'm like you
you shouldn't be a mother and i don't
say that because they're bad people but
they just don't have that nurturing
aspect to them and i think that you're
much better off having parents that want
to be parents and are deliberate about
it and are like i
like that is my calling i am a mother i
want to have kids i want to love them
and care for them
then you know push people into it that
won't be great parents because i think
the
you know obviously the catastrophic
uh
destruction of our family today and
you know marriage is falling apart all
of that has been one of the greatest
evils and one of the greatest scourges
on our civilization it all starts with
that minute factor not these big you
know big picture questions we're always
talking about so definitely a no for me
is there a thought though with because i
know exactly the type of young lady
you're talking about or you think oh
you're probably not going to be the most
nurturing but is there a thought of sort
of well just jump into the deep end you
know and just just do it and that will
transform you and your character yeah i
mean i think that does happen for some
people but
there's also the question of do you
really want to take that chance with the
child's life yeah yeah like would you
want your parents to be well we'll see
if it works out yeah i mean i'd be alive
at least but yes it could be it's a very
fraught prospect yeah i agree yeah very
intentional
it is more dangerous to be a white
farmer in south africa than a gay duck
who wrote these than a gay duck visiting
the united arab emirates
a gay duck
there were some years ago there were gay
penguins in the central park zoo
i think that they mean to write dude
i don't i'm gonna
gay duck
i'm sorry we shouldn't be joking because
it's actually really horrible to be a
white farmer in south africa like it's
it's horrendous and to be a gay duck in
the united arab emirates lauren please
don't downplay that okay i'm gonna have
your like real control here and say it's
a gay dude so it's more dangerous being
a white farmer in south africa
what is this guy taught
can i get a new producer please
when can i have a new person way better
than i do wow i think i may posted a
meme like three years ago of a duck
getting hanged in the united arab
emirates that's weird to follow those
memes that closely okay all right the
producers say it's done um wait you've
got to move mine
losing it here
uh yeah absolutely most people in the
united arab emirates are secretly gay
anyway
you know one time
this is true i was at a nightclub in in
dubai
and i'm there and a lot of people coming
over from abu dhabi or sharjah or
wherever or saudi arabia
and i met first of all their names were
mo
like muhammad but they didn't want to
say muhammad because i'm western so they
said i'm mo and
they were all gay guys they were all gay
guys just living it up in in dubai have
you ever heard this quote it's uh from
from that region but they'll say women
are for children boys are for pleasure
it's that's like genuinely a belief
system in in the
national army yeah you know the afghan
national army which briefly existed now
exists no more there was this big
problem of pederasty and one of the
lines that was reported to the uh
inspector general for afghanistan
reconstruction was what do you want me
i'll clean it up a little bit what do
you want me to do if i can't sleep with
little boys what am i supposed to sleep
with my grandmother it was a line
actually reported to the government so
yes also because the gay the gay ducks
can kind of maybe suppress it keep it in
check while they're in uae but the white
farmers you know unless they're going to
pull a justin trudeau which has its own
politically incorrect implications
they're not able to hide who they are
yeah
yeah okay true
okay justin trudeau is just ahead of the
curve
the jab is fake and is more likely just
a mark of the beast mechanism for
tracking people's movements controlling
population growth and possibly giving 5g
than actually preventing people from
getting sick
due to youtube well this is very
important due to youtube rules make your
guess and do not susan will check you do
not do not verbally confirm
if any other person guessed correctly
give only a non-verbal ambiguous gesture
so you're just saying you're just
guessing for the other person whether
you believe well no susan has already
guessed for us no but susan has already
yeah i
susan please don't take me down i don't
give a non-verbal yeah blink if you're
being held because we would never say
that the jab is obviously fake and i
can't even get through it they're going
to kick it they're going to ruin my
career i can't the jab is of course not
a mark of the beast and it is definitely
not a mechanism for tracking people's
movements or controlling population
growth
certainly not
okay all right okay drink to that drink
to our last youtube video yeah right
i've not seen borderless crossfire
farmlands or american mirage
i hate you
i assume you've seen it
no i've not seen my own oh no actually i
had a stand-in hold on it's not i have
not seen either or
american mirage isn't out yet that's
what i'm saying but i saw the other one
okay your first one i interviewed you
about the other one farmlands yeah
yeah okay yeah about that all right guys
you thought you had you thought you had
one on me but you don't because it was
in or
okay
the biggest issue with the legacy media
is that can i pause there i don't like
that term it makes them sound cool
legacy is cool i want a legacy i much
prefer establishment media lib media
crooked awful disgusting degenerate
media but legacy is a cool word
anyway it's a digression the biggest
issue with the legacy
the lib media yes thank you very much
thank you for interpreting that is that
it's controlled and influenced by a
group of people who are demographically
small yet vastly overrepresented in the
media where the hell is this going
hold on hold on
no before you no wait
blue jack twitter leftists okay
all right i thought we were having a
little bit of a
well we're having a little david duke on
the staff over here but we don't it's
talking about how
the libs the blue czech twitter leftists
control the establishment menus that
that's the biggest issue
with the media
you know are you drunk i that's not i'm
going to change my it's not that's not
the biggest issue what oh it's not it's
not the biggest issue with the lib media
is not that it's controlled by the small
handful of the blue checks and whatever
it's that they're wrong about everything
like it yeah but that's why they're
wrong i know it's related no they see
they are completely out of touch postal
elites that know nothing about the
average person
their experience of the real world all
comes from textbooks i totally agree
my point is though the media are always
going to be controlled by some elite
there's no such thing as a democratic
media where where every man has his own
news channel so it's always going to be
some elite some small group of people
that's fine by me i just want them to be
a good elite i'm actually kind of
pro-elite if the elite aren't just
disgusting dirt bags like they are today
so you like your hierarchy how very
conservative i know
you know it's a bit catholic yeah yeah
yeah
i wanted to be a good a good i want good
oppression that's what my my dad always
told me he was like lauren this is not a
democracy when i was growing up this is
a benevolent dictatorship
but right now we're living in a
malevolent dictator yes that's right the
family the family is not a democracy the
kingdom of heaven is not a democracy
yeah so the media is never going to be a
democracy
i just don't want it to be so damn
malevolent
is that too much to ask you probably so
if we can just have correct horrible
rich elites that would be great yeah
like you know i mean you know not all
rich people are bad just most of them
okay
i actually know what the phrase the new
world order means
i'm going to let you go
[Music]
yeah i mean
go for it susan's already going to kick
us off anyway
i mean
it's a group
of elites with interests that are
generally opposed to the average working
class individual and uh generally want
to acquire more power for themselves
and have a lot of control over the banks
our media our
politics
government souls it's been true since
the beginning this is the funny thing i
mean people go back they say
george h.w bush used the phrase in a
presidential address okay
or so-and-so or this guy or whatever
said this
it goes back as whitaker chambers says
to the garden of eden when the serpent
in the garden tells eve ye shall be his
gods right the idea of the new world
order
which really comes into fashion in
modernity in the in the
uh in light post enlightenment
is this idea that we're going to upend
every tradition that we ever had every
stable social institution every country
every all we're just going to upend all
of it and through our unfettered reason
we're going to create this utopia on
earth and and we're going to do it's not
going to be very democratic the way we
do it we're going to
shut you down and take away your
traditions and turn your boys into girls
and your girls into boys we're gonna do
but it's
the thing about the new world order is
that it's all the past is always evil
the present is always a crisis and the
future is always going to be great just
give us a little bit more power this
time we'll get it right this time we've
got it we swear yeah
yeah that's to the uh
to the old order to the old order i love
that
all right
this is me i think so
being a man has helped my career
[Music]
dare i ask why you would say no
for me i think that there's an
assumption from a lot of definitely
people on the right that uh
being a woman will further your career
just by virtue of being hot if which
isn't always the case for being a woman
by the way so that's an assumption and
um
also just by being rare the scarcity
in the right wing so because you are
a right-wing commentator you might
assume that uh being a woman and being
more scarce as a right would be good or
would assist women might are probably as
represented among conservatives as men
but among
commentators commentators they're much
rarer correct that's a good point that's
true
that's true
listen i'm of italian extraction
okay
i
am a very traditional guy i like to
think that
whatever charms i may possess they
they're more of a masculine aspect okay
i don't know i'm not i don't know i i
wouldn't know how to be a woman
and furthermore
if i were
a lady
i would i be doing all of this would i
be putting myself through this rigmarole
this month this this monstrous sort of
life day by day in and day out admiring
myself in the muck and the yuck of the
liberal madness and going out and no i
probably would i'd find a rich guy i'd
find a rich hunk
and i would batten down the hatches and
i'd have a good life
yeah so i guess you're right it hasn't
helped my career i'd have a much better
career if i were a lady
turning into a man was absolutely
helpful to my career
that video did great on an unironic
level though there are two
there is the fast track if you are a
woman that you can choose where you can
sleep your way to the top like that is
an option
you can you can do that but there's the
uh
other side where if you choose not to it
will genuinely hurt you like
a lot of people do not take rejection
well and they will get you back for that
as a woman and uh
you know i can legitimately say i have
lost opportunities for rejecting guys i
didn't want to i didn't want to press
too much to put so you've experienced
this oh yeah absolutely and i don't want
it like ah feminists have made it so
hard to talk about any legitimate
what's his name
what's his phone number where do i get
him yeah yeah how do i dox him and then
they also complain about like oh like a
guy like vaguely flirted with me like
that's rape or whatever it's just made
it impossible to talk about genuine
problems in this but like yeah if you if
you
reject a guy or maybe it probably
happens the other way around too with
women like that jilted reaction
especially amongst highly
narcissistic personalities can uh be
disastrous he'll happen if you're
no fury like a narcissistic scorn
exactly so i would say that there there
are benefits and there are absolutely
women that can use that to their
advantage but if you don't know how to
use that and you aren't someone who
wants to take advantage of that
then they're every every everything
comes with the flip side right that's
true i i would genuinely if uh i would
genuinely
um going and filming my documentaries i
would prefer to be a man while doing
that just for safety reasons yeah
running around south africa yeah i think
it's probably a better idea to be a
fella and then you get imposter syndrome
too because it's like oh it
you know do people actually like it
is it actually a good documentary or is
it just because i'm a woman i know this
is what that's what i always ask myself
i said do people really like my
commentary or is it just because i'm
sexy
is it just because i'm hot hot to trot
it's so hard to be you it is hard i i
did i did find this in hollywood though
i would go i'd walk in you know to the
big lots
knock on the knock on mr weinstein's
door i see mr weinstein
i'm yours
dude
i'm here i'm here to be a big star and i
don't know then the door would slam in
my face
i'm really sorry that that happened to
you i know i guess it's probably better
it's probably good that the guy's behind
bars now probably it's probably good
but i don't know if it helped my career
i'm really sorry that that happened to
you truly his rejection of you is the
real crime yes
on that note lauren uh one last drink
one last drink cheers this was great
thank you to your health
there's someone that you would like to
see me play the game with again it has
to be a man i'm glad we didn't break my
rule uh please leave it in the comments
we'll see you next time on yes or no
[Music]
[Music]